what we've chosen to do with this car
mat is actually offers something which
is a little bit more focused in
specification for the enthusiast driver
very much drawing on the motorsport
heritage that Aston Martin is famous for
and as you can see very distinctive both
visually form the exterior and pulling
on those motorsport cues but equally
importantly underneath the bonnet here
we've got the normally aspirated v8 430
brake horsepower engine in this car 361
pound-feet of torque
nought to sixty four point six seconds
190 mile an hour and this truly is a car
that is very very comfortable on the
track but equally as is all our Vantage
is a car which is very functional can be
driven on the road perhaps the most
important thing about this couch I think
will surprise a number of people is that
this car is priced at $99,000 and I
think the same most people might expect
Aston Martin's to to be a little higher
than that so that's great I think the
most important thing about it is that
you can still get it in a stick shift
you see so many of the high-end sports
car manufacturers going to automatic
gearboxes what drives you to keep it
sort of more traditional which demand
and one of the things that you know
we've recognized with Vantage is this
very much as a driver's car
it's why it's been so successful in the
in the motorsports environment 30% of
our our cars here in North America are
our stick shift and that's why this car
comes as a standard as a manual but you
also have the automated manual as well
7-speed for those customers who who want
to to try something different
how much do you expect to sell on this
because I have read sales targets of
maybe double the sales by 2016 you want
a boost production okay we'd like to
grow production and we'd like to grow
sales and I think this car gives us an
opportunity to do so but let's not
forget I mean that's the man is very
exclusive last year we sold just over
four thousand cars and you know we see
the Vantage
market of about 30% in terms of our
sales we'd like to sell a few more cars
and we believe that this will offer an
opportunity just to broaden our appeal
and bring a few more customers to the
ground you've got some agreements with
with Daimler Benz
now that you made last year in exchange
for a 5% equity stake they're gonna
supply engines electronics transmissions
when are we gonna see that go into
effect
well you're right we do have a technical
partnership that either we've announced
with with Mercedes what that is is it's
not necessarily a supply deal but it
gives us the opportunity to work with
Daimler and their associated partners in
terms of developing custom aston martin
products for the future so the v8
engines the power trains and the
electronics as well and all that will
come as part of our overall development
in terms of the aston portfolio we're
investing about five hundred million
pound over eight hundred million dollars
in terms of new new product over the
course of the next five years so it's
very exciting times for us and we're
looking forward to to seeing some of
that new product of the course of the
next three four five years you continue
to compete with with the biggest brands
as well but most of them are now owned
by or at least working with huge major
car makers how difficult is it to stay
competitive and stay independent okay we
have a unique position that we are well
funded well capitalized and you know we
have that opportunity to to react very
quickly to the market and so for us you
know we're very confident where we are
today and what we do it's hard to kind
of just oppose the concept of owning it
for the track building up its horsepower
or building up its torque and bringing
the price down how do you how do you put
those two together well we're looking to
offer a distinctive package here and
something which we think will appeal and
just broaden the opportunity for for
aston martin and we recognize that that
competitive segment under the $100,000
has grown exponentially over the course
of the last few years we believe we have
a very compelling proposition and this
is it map the GT